Ron there's an old statement I've read
and heard about people saying in
Congress the banks never lose I think
that's a general statement I think the
big bankers never lose out I think a
little banker right now I was losing
love because a lot of little bankers are
getting closed down the big banks are
gobbling them up I don't think David
Rockefeller is going to lose I don't
think he's going to be out selling
apples or pushing pencils anytime soon
but a lot of bankers that are being
wiped out that the state-level are
losing but the big banking power
structure seems to have control because
they're on the inside and they have
control of money and they know what
policy is going to be down the road can
you specify this structure that you're
talking about this power structure well
the power structure basically is made up
of a lot of very powerful business and
corporate leaders in the country and
it's in particularly they have formed
their organizations they've been around
for good Wow they don't even hide it
anymore you know the trilateral
committee Commission as well as the
council formulation no matter what which
president which party is in power they
will appoint to the major offices
members of these two committees and
they're always they they always have
control of the federal reserve system so
the Wall Streeters the big bankers have
inside information as far as what is
happening what's going on and control
over money is pretty significant because
if you can control money you're really
controlling one half of every single
transaction so that is a tremendous
amount of power but it doesn't look like
we're going to have any independence
they say that the Federal Reserve is
independent but that's a bunch of
nonsense the protection that the
founders gave us to try to keep us from
this happening never authorized a
central bank and they were very strict
in the writing of the Constitution to
limit the power of Congress to only to
the minting of gold coins to allowing
only gold and silver to be legal tender
in prohibiting the printing of paper
money all those things we have failed to
follow that's why we have a
from bank with a paper money system and
a lot of inflation high interest rates
in a very very shaky economy so I would
say that if we would have followed the
advice of the founding fathers and not
allowed this power structure this group
of elitist bankers and industrialists to
get control not only of the banking
system in the monetary system but really
our foreign policy and our government I
wrote a little speech and gave a speech
right before I left Congress and I said
I don't think the members of Congress
really know how little effect they have
in controlling things really this and
that means that the Congress that itself
doesn't have much control the people
doesn't have much they don't have much
to say about it either the control of
overall policy is really in the hands of
a very small number of people who
control all the administration's all the
appointments to cabinets and certainly
all the appointments to the Federal
Reserve that shows we have a single
party political system in the United
States just maybe split into a little
bit but think it's a single party if you
look at the obstacles put in our way as
libertarians get on ballots it's it's an
outrage because we have to spend more
than a third of our energies and our
money's just to apply to get on state
ballots and and this distracts us some
states it's almost impossible to get on
they say and I have not personally
investigated every law around the world
but they say that we are one of the
toughest countries in the world to get a
new part insisted an American people
been conditioned that it's great to have
two parties we don't want to be like
Italy where there's all these choices we
want to limit our choices it's easier
that way and we don't want to be like
Soviet Union where there's only one
party yeah that's right so they have to
but if policies never change what's the
difference so we do have one party
there's policies never change you know
if there would have been a difference
maybe under the Republicans we would
have had a closer to a balanced budget
but the deficits were worse with the
Republicans but foreign policy the
policy of intervention subsidizing
communism and helping rich allies that
always continues Republican they're
Democrats
it was the same policy Republican or
Democrat that supported wars like Korea
and Vietnam and the CIA operations in
the FBI all these operations are
by the by the other two parties but in
that for that reason what do they do
they control the funding as well the
other two parties get over a hundred
million dollars handed to them you know
not too long ago we had the two
conventions on national television
Republican Democratic convention the
American people didn't watch they should
have they paid for it they paid nine
million dollars we as citizens were
forced to pay to run those conventions
nine million dollars a piece and
therefore they get all this exposure
making it again very difficult for an
auction a third option to be heard it's
a very hard to get our message out but
the control is there whether it's in the
political control or the banking control
or in government policy control in the
administration's I want to touch if I
may just on your comment a moment ago
about the departing speech that you left
with your colleagues in Congress and you
were there for four terms and I think
are aware of the general level of
awareness of your colleagues in Congress
at that time do they really not know
that that all of this is going on that
the power structure is there unseen but
really manipulating the strings most of
them don't know most of them are
suspicious that there are the problems
of more serious than they would never
ever admit publicly but they don't
understand the policies I've had a lot
of members on the Banking Committee come
up and ask me question how does the
Federal Reserve System work
what are Special Drawing rights how what
is the IMF and they'll do that quietly
because they haven't really studied it
so most of them are naive but very much
aware that there's some serious problem
but if you get somebody that's a head of
a committee it's been around for thirty
years or so I think that they know very
much what's happening
they're very much attuned to what's
happening and I don't think they get
that far I don't think they get the head
of a committee unless they've more or
less been accepted you know by the power
structure I did a study or just a quick
look a few years ago after reading the
joint economic report a Joint Economic
Committee in Congress and reading it it
looked like it came right out of the
trilateral commission you look all the
little buzz words that the trilateral
commission reports had all the things
that's trilateral commission wanted that
so I looked to see if in the memberships
of organizations of these the
congressmen and Senators and sure enough
almost every one of her member
trilateral commission of Bilderberger or
Council on Farley I can remember having
a conversation with barber Conable one
day she's a biggie at the party and he
was he was complaining about you know
there's people always complaining about
me belonging to the trilateral
commission he was complaining to me and
lo and behold it was barber Conable but
as soon as he resigned from Congress
where he end up the head of the World
Bank you know I I left Congress I
studied the banking system I understand
something about the money they even
called me yeah to motive those
appointments now I've been waiting at
the telephone waiting for them to
appointment but John you've studied a
lot of this banking industry structure
and it's not only interlocked here but
they're international interlocked center
yes there are and they ties with the
foreign banking interest we the people
that settled this country and left of
course Europe came over here and settled
down and almost immediately the the
powers that be in the European continent
and the money circles were reaching out
those tentacles to gain control of the
new country here and that struggle has
continued we see it and who shall
control our currency they struggled back
between Jefferson as a matter of fact I
have a quote from Jefferson that I think
is very pertinent to our discussion here
if the American people ever allow the
banks to control the issuance of their
currency first by inflation and then by
deflation the banks and corporations
that will grow up around them would
deprive the people of all
property until their children will wake
up homeless on the continent their
fathers occupied so he warned us that
Fargo and here we are and his what he
said is coming true yes in his side
certainly one to fight back then they
got the right position in the
Constitution they had a debate over the
money issue the hard money people won
the Federalists lost the Hamiltonians
lost but then subsequently it's been
downhill and certainly in this century
it never happens at one time you know it
isn't all or nothing they keep changing
away even though we got our central bank
in 1913 it wasn't a total destruction of
the system it literally took from 1913
to 1971 to open up the floodgates but it
was in 71 that the last linkage to gold
occurred of course in the 60s there was
still some linkage to silver but since
71 all you have to do is look at the
economic record of spending and deficits
and all the economic problems and
interest rates and all the price
increases I mean it's just been totally
out of control and then even in 1980
there was another law that increased
tremendously the power reserves in those
savings loan yeah the most significant
increase in power to the Federal Reserve
System occurred since 1913 was in 1980
further enhancing and getting more power
into the Federal Reserve this was a time
when they introduced this idea that we
could use anything or the Federal
Reserve could use anything as an asset
to collateralize our Federal Reserve now
see in the old days you'd have gold and
silver as collateral to issue a note
which isn't too bad you know it's
collateral it would restrict the
monetary authorities and it would be a
certificate you know would be a
guaranteed certificate but it was then
that they changed it to say that you
could use any asset even a foreign bond
so it's true now that you can use and
they have use foreign bonds they put it
in the Federal Reserve and that's the
backing
that's the collateral our Federal
Reserve that's how strong our currency
is you wonder how the currency works it
doesn't deserve to work and someday that
people going to wake up and realize the
money's worthless and that's when you
don't have runaway inflation today
we just have gradual steady inflation
depreciation of the money causing a lot
of harm and in suffering one day where
the countries would wake up and there's
going to be a catastrophe I want to
focus on the and the Federal Reserve
itself for a moment in that I wonder you
know what percentage of the people know
that the Federal Reserve is not really a
part of the government a privately owned
corporation and who owns that you know
the Federal Reserve well could you have
a comment on that well I think very few
people understand how it works because
the members of Congress weren't really
not very much aware of it but I think
it's a little bit worse than just saying
it's private you know if it were just
private
they'd have to live within the laws of
the land or odd and they would have to
be a public corporation and you know it
open there's a public corporation you
have a right to know what your
corporation is doing if you unstuck and
be audited here it's secret but where do
they get their power is it the power of
the marketplace that creates this
corporation no they in addition to being
very secretive have their authorization
their creation from government so
government creates them and they create
a specialty so it's much worse than just
being a private corporation it is a very
secretive private government ordained
corporation that has the power to
counterfeit money so it's very very
unique and much worse than just being
private it's the secrecy of it and the
power that it gets through government
legislation that makes it so evil now
you were the ranking Republican on the
House Banking Committee for a while one
of the subcommittee's not on the entire
committee and do I understand correctly
that members of Congress are can't even
go to the Fed meetings that's why I was
very interested in the issue and I was
on three subcommittees to being on
coinage and domestic monetary policy
subcommittee but I could not go to a
meeting I couldn't get an audit I could
even check the books and the other ones
who create the money yet I was I felt
like I was elected to be responsible to
the people when I would be inquisitive
and looking into these things their
attitude is when you need to know or
when the people need to know will tell
you they're in charge and we're just on
the outside looking in rather than the
people being in charge of the government
sending me or somebody
they're congressmen to control the
bureaucrats but turn it upside down they
have control and they allow us to know
what we want and what they think we
should know now what does the Federal
Reserve System actually do I have so
many people say you know I see this and
the Federal Reserve I don't know what
the Federal Reserve Bank does and why is
it it 6oc well it does several things
one of the benign things it does and in
some ways efficiently and that is they
exchange checks you know they're an
exchange Bureau but that could be done
very easily privately the real evil that
they do is they create money and credit
if the federal government runs up a debt
and they tend to have a habit of doing
this you know Congress is you know run
by Republicans and Democrats say they
all spent money they run up the debt of
course they when they spend they have to
tax us if they can't tax enough then
they have to borrow and if they can't
borrow enough then they have one other
option they can tax and borrow inflate
inflate the most important thing to
remember is inflating is not the prices
and the prices go up after the money is
inflated and the money loses its value
so the Fed is designed to accommodate
the politician in a very secretive
manner the politicians spend the money
because the special interest kind of
thing we want this we want this the
politician gets reelected so he's
rewarded and the tax becomes an indirect
tax instead of going directly to the
people what we what the Federal Reserve
does is they can take a Treasury bill
except the Treasury bill which now is
just a mirror computer entry they accept
the Treasury bill of ten billion dollars
and they give Treasury ten billion
dollars in their checking account where
did the Federal Reserve get the money
right out of thin air right from heaven
they create the money they put it in the
checking account in this Harry spends it
and then that means that the people who
got that money immediately get to spend
it it has value but as it circulates in
the economy the value of the purchasing
power of the money goes down and you
have prices going up the the bad part
about this is not everybody suffers
equally if the money supply went up 10%
and every one of us had to cost a living
go up ademma case 10% it wouldn't be
nearly the great harm but be
cause of the system it's designed
literally the benefit the politicians
and the bankers and big corporations
those who get the money they get the
money they get the benefit and then
somebody else in a year or two or three
suffers the consequences we read about
the Federal Reserve as a bankers bank
and we see them that they raise the
discount rate or they increase the money
supply what all these things mean
well the bankers bank means literally
that the bankers are required to put
their deposits in the Federal Reserve
System and they're accountable their
Federal Reserve System they have to send
in the reports the Federal Reserve the
Federal Reserve has all these
regulations and rules so they control
the whole entire banking system if in
the in their efforts to fine tune
although they literally destroy the
money they don't want to destroy the
money they want to control things so
when inflation gets perking along
they're aware the same economic thoughts
that I'm aware of and they know that if
they're not a little bit cautious about
this they could have you know runaway
inflation so they tend to back off but
they benefit from the backing off that
means they tighten the credit raise the
interest rates and cause a recession and
they do it in the name of saving the
economy which they have to or the
currency gets out of control but if they
know it's coming then they benefit on it
too then they benefit they know then to
be in cash in or and I interest rates
and the banks benefit by it so they
whether the economy's going up or down
if they are designing the policy they
can they can catch the swing so it's the
inside information they that they have
but they didn't give the recession's
which are literally the results of the
inflation the system would crumble much
faster but our argument as hard money
people is that in spite of their
arrogance to think that they can keep
this going forever and as powerful as
they are the market is more powerful see
for decades they kept the gold price at
$35 an ounce I said we will regulate the
price of gold but they kept printing the
money that market finally broke down the
price of gold
well the marketplace will finally win
out and the people will wake up and say
it's all paper it's all a scam and
that's when there's chaos and that's
when the paint
realize they're getting out of control
and that's when the connection of the
bankers to the politicians is critical
because then power is threatened so
that's when they then they come down
with political controls of our lives
that's why the emergency powers are
already written the president can
declare an emergency and take over the
industries and take over our lives and
confiscate to go and that's why we
should be concerned we should be
concerned for you know our prosperity
you know our standard of living and all
but our greatest concern on to me that
when these crises come in the market it
disrupts this political system in this
monetary system then we are threatened
by political power taking away more of
our personal liberties this the FEMA
regulations are you're tired of down
under the FEMA the emergency powers and
it came up even in the Contra hearings
that there were emergency powers written
a matter of fact that great hero Oliver
North was in participating in designing
some of these to literally if necessary
suspend the Constitution these are the
kind of things are common I don't know
if you were set on the concentration
camps so this was brought up in the FEMA
in the iran-contra hearings remember
they immediately suppress it and they
say this is something we can't discuss
that yes very good people weren't a lot
of know about this and that's why who
who protected this information who
protected all over North the head
Democrat which case you show you the
power structures to see John you made a
big study in the history of the Federal
Reserve how did it come about
what's a murky story and I think that
maybe 1913 not to be the year they went
down in infamy in American history
because not only do we get just barely
in 1913 the Federal Reserve we also got
the income tax in the very same year and
those two things have worked to our
didn't really been a very negative thing
in our society our economy ever since
that time but it was a very secretive
thing it really goes back to the bankers
getting in a sealed railway car and
sneaking off to Jekyll Island Georgia
and it was a very secret meeting in fact
they called it the first name Club they
only called each other by their first
name so that even people who work there
as
waiters and servants and so forth later
couldn't identify for sure who had even
participated in that meeting it was only
about four or five people it was about
10 I believe Gordon or 12 and that group
of people literally laid the basis for
what became the Federal Reserve
basically rockefeller Morgan people
though that group you probably know
something in that area of house there's
in law there and the Woodrow Wilson
people were there although this occurred
I believe in 1910 or so when they met at
my house that's right there's a couple
of years later a time they got planned
it was finally passed in 1913 it was
kind of sneaked through Congress and
Wilson actually signed that into law the
Federal Reserve Act like two days before
Christmas and when many of the senators
and congressmen of course with
transportation in 1913 Dean what it was
they had long since left the nation
Capitol many of them but the ones that
they wanted to stay and vote did stay
and vote Wilson signed the law two days
before Christmas and traditionally
hasn't that been a period whereby
gentlemen's agreement the important
legislation is not enacted right around
the Christmas holiday it may be a
gentlemen's agreement but that's
generally at the time that I was always
most vigilant because I realize that's
where most of garbage pass the most of
the more onerous you know in the last
day of the session is unbelievable
stacks and stacks of pieces of
legislation come in nobody reads
anything so the worst things happen at
particular time but it is supposed to be
that if the members aren't attending
that they wouldn't be doing these kind
of things but you're absolutely right
there was a very low attendance and and
it was it was an unusual year because
generally Congress didn't meet that late
of the year and I don't know whether
they were called back into session went
but it was unusual for Congress back in
those days now it's very common to meet
all year round so back then they were
usually only in session two or three
months of the year but here they were in
session in December very unusual year
and one of the most important pieces of
legislation certainly in our history
kind of just rushed through at the last
minute without anyone really paying that
much attention to it and I think was so
interesting there there were a lot of
people who weren't fooled a lot of the
congressman from the western part of the
United States even the South more
populous areas
weren't fooled by what was happening
they recognize it as a gravy train going
to the bankers so they naturally were
opposed to it and in reading book secret
or Federal Reserve I thought it was
fascinating that the bankers set up an
organization to complain about this
Federal Reserve Act which was there they
were secretly would say secretly hatched
up and they were secretly trying to get
past but they complained that it was
going to kill him just so it would the
people would think that oh well we're
going to pass this and it will harness
the banks yet they were literally
getting a license to steal because that
really permitted this fractional reserve
banking system to occur where they can
pyramid their deposits loan out money
that they don't even have so it was a
tremendous benefit to the bankers
nothing of this that you'll find in
history books or books on government or
economic history the United States
nothing about how they're certainly not
teaching in school not in history class
all these schools hopefully we will see
that it's gets taught some way let's
come forward from 1913 to the Depression
era and the role that the Fed played in
that the inflation deflation cycle would
you like to comment on that yes a lot of
people you can still find in history
books that the economists were reassured
in the 1920s that there was no inflation
prices were relatively stable and they
always said that inflation was rising
prices but if you look at the monetary
history there was a lot of monetary
inflation during the 1920s and the money
instead of going into production
it went into speculation of course it
bit up the price of stocks and real
estate and then it finally came to that
time when there is concern or they make
the decision look I think we think we
can not only save the dollar and stop
the inflation but we can make some money
on and they say we're going to have to
turn this off so they cut back on the
credit and it caused the stock market
crash and of course then a Great
Depression followed the introduced
inflation always leads to a correction
of the need of a recession or depression
if you compare what happened in 1920 is
very similar what's happening here in
the 1980s and you just think about how
many times you read in the last six or
eight years that the government stole
there's nothing to worry about there's
no inflation where there's been a
greater expansion of money now than it
was in the 20s of course there was a
greater speculation in stock market and
a bigger stock market crash so I
anticipate and many Austrians
free-market economists anticipate that
the recession that's coming will not be
a recession at all to be a depression
probably bigger than when we have the
1930s because it will be the correction
for all the malinvestment all the
mistakes made because of this artificial
credit pumped in by the Federal Reserve
System so we have to look for the
correction the next president will be
blamed for the depression but it is that
they shouldn't get to blame it should be
the Faubourg policy in the regular
ministration and the Congress today who
have run up the debts and created the
new money that has set the stage for the
next recession the next recession or
slant depression if it becomes that do
you have an idea in mind for when that
might begin we see all these books out
now the Great Depression of 1990 and I
have an idea but the most important
thing about Austrian economics is that
you cannot project precisely because
events occur with emotional aspects
human beings making decisions that's why
although many including myself kept
saying there's going to be a stock
market right but I didn't know it was
going to be October 19 they could have
been October 10th or could have been
November 15 I mean it comes when people
just get frightened and scared and panic
so Austrian economics teaches that yes
we know a depression is coming but we
don't know the day it's going to start
but still a lot of people say well what
do you think because you just have to
make a judgment for personal and
financial reasons I think it's going to
there's going to be another major
financial event before the end of this
year close to the election more likely
before that afterwards and that by next
year next spring it will be very clear
that this country is moving rapidly into
a recession we put that question to
congressman Gonzalez your former
colleague on the housing banking
currency committee
and I said well I've been reading a lot
about how the next presidents going to
be the next Herbert Hoover and he said
if we're lucky the depression won't wait
that long and I wouldn't argue a whole
lot but but time is running short here
we are in August already and a recession
could start tomorrow or the next day it
could be very clear I think matter of
fact the standard of living has been
going down I think history is going to
show that the country has been down on
the down slope maybe for the past ten
years it's just not going rapidly and
it's not confirmed by the government
statistics but they're changing all the
time they use GNP figures to reassure us
everything is okay and 40 percent of GNP
is government spending and where do they
get the money they print it and also you
know like for CPI they change in that if
it's going up too fast they change the
way they calculate it if you go to the
average guy on the street and say is
your cost of living going on because I
can't even pay my bills I'm not even
buying the steak anymore and so things
are a lot worse than the government
leads to believe can we get back to this
matter of political power ikan economic
power and control of the economy were
you in Congress when Wright Patman was
still there no but I was in Congress
when his son was there oh yeah I think
it's Bill Patman that was there but I
didn't know Wright Patman Wright Patman
of course was the chairman of the
Banking Committee one time and he had
some good ideas about the Federal
Reserve oh he had in my Studies on the
American power structure it was a real
gold mine because his committee the one
which you came on later made studies of
how the big banks the United States
control the corporations in the United
States and it's incredible
through interlocking directorates in
stock ownership which they I guess did
you see much of this while you were
there
not in the detail that he had looked at
it but it's obviously very clear the one
thing I picked up from Wright Patman was
his bill to audit the Federal Reserve
and I've only made minor modifications
to I dug that out and and he of course
was a champion of openness in government
he wanted to know what the Federal
Reserve was doing and he never finally I
think in his older years they had voted
him out of that power position you know
even before he was out of Congress he
lost his position they put in Henry's
Royce it was much more control by the
banking people but he he was good person
and he wanted more openness I don't know
if he was as strong on the gold standard
as I am but he certainly was against the
type of banking system and how that how
the banking system the Federal Reserve
serve the interests of the bankers and
large corporations the bankers control
the mass media the way they control
other major industries in the United
States probably so certainly a lot of
people say that I guess I hesitate only
that I don't have you know the proof
sitting in my hand but I think it's very
clear I can see it in government and I
saw it in banking and certainly it can't
be surprising if they're involved with
other large corporations why the media
would be very much involved - it would
be more of a surprise to find that not
to be the case but I don't think I could
take them into court right now and give
them that proof that is necessary but I
think those who have studied it filled
of that is the case can you see this
scenario assume that your elected
president of the United States are
sitting in the Oval Office can you see
yourself signing a bill or a directive
abolishing the Federal Reserve well a
lot would have to happen you know if if
I went there and I was a libertarian
president and the Congress remained the
same and the spending was continuing and
the people still wanted all this big
government no I can't I can't sign a
bill because it would have been passed
in the first four years of a libertarian
administration I don't think we're going
to achieve that unless we're picking up
the pieces you know and I don't want
that to happen I'd like to avoid the
chaos and that's my goal but if there's
if there's an economic calamity and they
look to
the libertarians for solutions that I
think it's conceivable but that be more
like being a profit than somebody
running for president you know and and I
just don't know how has happened will
happen but I do believe though if we
continue to do what we're doing continue
to spend run up the deficit print to
money I think we are going to have the
crisis but right now I'm terrified to
think that the people in Washington
aren't going to look to us for the
answers they're going to enforce these
emergency powers and FEMA will be in
control not the American people can you
did your committee look into the matter
of the debt which foreign countries owed
to the so-called US banks yes that's
been done going in certainly 1982 was a
key year because there was a big bailout
of Mexico and Argentina and Brazil in
order to patch it together and they did
everything illegal just like it was
illegally done even admitted by Dawn
Reagan who was Secretary of Treasury
time it was the illegal on how they
bailed out continental Illinois and they
do whatever is necessary to keep the
structure together the system together
if big banks gobble up little banks but
nothing disintegrates it's not like what
was happening in 1920's 1930's
and they'll do whatever is necessary so
that's what happened back in 1982 they
work internationally to the Federal
Reserve the Treasury the World Bank Bank
of International Settlements which is
the depository for all the central banks
so you have the Federal Reserve banks
depositing in the Federal Reserve System
but the central banks of the United
States and all the other countries used
the Bank of International Settlements in
Switzerland to be the internationals
bankers bank and they all got involved
to keep the structure together and they
did they restored order that was back
when gold went quickly from 300 dollars
up to 500 dollars within a six-month
period but then they saw that the market
is that up it looks like are going to
hold it together for a while longer and
they certainly have at the expense of
the American taxpayer and at the expense
of the dollar
of course since then the dollars value
has gone down 40 50 percent in value of
other currency prices
continue to rise but eventually my
argument is that the marketplace will
overwhelm even those men of great power
and there will be a panic that the
bankers won't be able to maintain and
then they will want to maintain their
power but not by not by fine-tuning the
economy then by the intimidation of
political force I noticed very little
talked about thing that this is from the
alternative press where the head of the
Fed Paul Volcker got a little bill or a
little sentence on a writer on a bill
passed through Congress that if
necessary the foreign debt of these
third world countries to the US banks
would be monitor eyes would use just way
of saying that the US taxpayers would
pay for it yes this was part of that
monetary Control Act and that means that
if the Fed can hold any asset they can
hold a foreign bond they literally under
the law today can buy a Mexican bond
that's worthless put it in the Federal
Reserve and then what monetized means is
that it can be collateral for issuing
credit issuing Federal Reserve notes and
that will be considered an asset
probably at face value they're not going
too deep I mean the bond isn't going to
be worth anything obviously but they can
monetize that that is mean they will
take it as an asset create new money and
distribute the money so that isn't a
direct bailout by attacks it's it's
probably it's an indirect because what
we do is we buy the mexican bond and
then put the bond in the federal reserve
but actually it works twice because
let's say the mexican bond is a billion
dollars worth of mexican bonds down
there so the Fed says well we'll buy
them you need some hard cash will buy
your bond from you and we give them the
money and they take that out of out of
the system and they send it to them but
then when they take it's an asset it
becomes an asset to the Federal Reserve
and I say ah we have something we can
back up our currency with so they take
this worthless instrument that they pay
for with fiat money and then they put it
in their assets and then they create use
that to create more money so they really
monetize it twice so to speak
how closely tied is the Federal Reserve
System and the US banking system with
the European banking system the
Rothschild cetera the international
bankers are buddies you know in there
they're closer together and they deal
with policy outside most of the
legislative institutions the central
bankers are more powerful than say the
Congress is of the different countries
they have much more power and therefore
through the Bank of International
Settlement and the IMF and the World
Bank they have total control of this and
they have meetings where even the
secretary of the Treasury doesn't attend
it's strictly the bankers the full
Reserve and the Bundestag and all the
other banks of the world they get
together and they make these plans and
that's why they come up with the bailout
systems you know if there's a banking
crisis someplace but they they will do
whatever they think is necessary by the
creation of new credit right now they
have made the agreement that they will
create more the Special Drawing rights
which is nothing more than credit
instruments in the IMF they create them
out of thin air they have a monetary
value in all based in all currencies and
they can give those to whomever needs
them and they've just agreed to create
40 billion dollars worth of new Special
Drawing rights out of thin air
now what then is the role of the IMF it
seems to me that the taxpayers money
goes to the IMF they give it to the
third world country which in turn turns
it back over to the banks it looks like
and a lot of it just goes directly from
you know the taxpayers directed to the
bank it never goes to third world's on a
computer but that was you know a few
years back I guess it was 83 there was
an IMF bailout they were in financial
trouble it was nine billion dollars most
of that money was necessary to pay
interest you know just to the big banks
that's why the Panama Canal treaty
existed it was a banking deal - it was
Panama was having trouble making their
payments to the banks and they need a
better cash flow the canal treaty
occurred they had more income now there
or old Noriega isn't quite so obedient
and they're a little bit annoyed by it
all but you know Trujillo's and then
Noriega would really the hand-picked
people from our business banking
industry they had a banking hanging down
there
but now Noriega isn't quite so beady and
it's making the bankers a little nervous
they'd like to get rid of them and so
for I haven't been able to and I think
one of the reasons is he has a lot of he
has a lot of information and he is
threatened with they said if you ever
get to closes we're going to let the
world know exactly how you've been
dealing with us in subsidizing our drug
trade so I think he's doing a little
blackmail people who've studied the drug
trade say that if we're not for the
collusion and facilitation and
laundering of money by the big banks the
drug trade wouldn't be able of Murray
they'd have a great deal difficulty
because they literally end up buying
some of these banks and they own the
banks and and they do you know filter
their money through now there's a great
pretense that there's going to be a lot
of crackdown on all these drug deals and
this money coming into that and they're
going to find out who it is but I think
that's basically designed to use as an
excuse develop this hysteria against
drugs so that they have currency
controls on whom on American citizens
who finally wise up and say hey I can't
preserve my wealth in this country I'm
going to put a couple Krugerrands over
in this over into Swiss banks so they
try to take everybody with near the time
of runaway inflation people want to take
the money out of the country to preserve
their well and that's why they're men
doing writing all these laws not catch
the drug dealers I think that's just
doesn't you know a you know a front I
think the real reason is to have
currency controls on American citizens
because once a large number of citizens
decide to lead this thing of how many
people in Mexico tried to come here when
their banking crisis occurred you know
the government clamped on you can't take
money out they still did but we we had
those weak credit controls in the 1970s
currency controls trying to keep people
Britain had them on off and on and
they'll all they always resort to those
kind of things so we can anticipate it
but I think that's one of the
the big drug issue is order to write
these laws so that they control innocent
American people who would like to
preserve their wealth but they could
clamp they could do away with the dope
trade pretty fast
they really clamp down on the big banks
but they're the head people in the power
structure that's right but they're not
likely to do this John you've taken a
look at foreign investment in the United
States some of those statistics haven't
it's startling when you when you look at
it all and then one lump sum Ron you're
from Houston and there was a story
recently about Houston prime real estate
there being about 36% foreign owned that
occurred in USA Today a front-page story
prime real estate in Los Angeles 49% 46%
something like that foreign owned we're
seeing investments every day banks being
bought
commercial properties farmland and the
article that I saw there was a study
released last month on it that it's the
foreign investment total in the United
States now is an excess of 1.3 trillion
dollars and growing at a tremendous rate
we call it the liquidation sale of
America why is it happening there are
several reasons why it's happening but I
think in a lot of those investments are
made by Japanese Japanese investors I
think it's rather interesting to note
that we had to fight a war not too many
years ago with Japan we thought we won
the war and now they own not only a lot
of Houston in Los Angeles they own walk
in Key Beach they won due to our bad
policy what they could win in war the
main reason is it's it's our SiC
currency we have a balance of trade
problem but we compounded by literally
exporting a lot of our money through
foreign aid and military aid so even
Japan gets a benefit of 50 billion
dollars a year by us paying for all
their national defense so we sort of
subsidize them and because we're less
competitive in our interest rates are
high our interest rate is 8 9% in Japan
they're 2 and 3% labour costs are lower
so we can't compete anymore and that's
why we keep buying Japanese products a
lot of people say well the only solution
is is to write a law and say that
Americans can't buy Japanese car and no
foreign investors
I'd invest in this country we as
lesbians don't accept that it's treating
the symptom rather than disease the
disease as a foreign policy where we
subsidize these rich allies at the same
time we have a currency this week we
have economic conditions that have made
us non-competitive we don't want to take
away the right of the individual to buy
whatever product he wants and we don't
want to start some type of walling off
of our country and saying nobody can
come and go and people can't come in I
want a right to go out of the country
than this and that means we have to
allow somebody else to come in here and
so our solution is free markets sound
money low interest rates competitiveness
free market prices in labour
quit subsidizing Japan a different
foreign policy then I don't think you
would have to work we never had to worry
about the foreigners line up this
country until recent times until until
we got into these economic problems but
it's curious people who say we shouldn't
keep financing the defense of Western
Europe and Japan and yet it's those
people who are buying American
securities and financing our deficits so
they are inter foreigners yeah so they
are indirectly paying for their own
defense
you know there is there's some truth to
that and I think there's a been a deal
to I think that sometimes they're buying
our debt when it doesn't make a whole
lot of sense but you have to think about
again of this internationalism they do
this in order to maintain their order
for their benefits so even if it isn't
to Japan central bank's interest you
know to buy our securities for a strict
economic they might be able to buy
somebody else's security and make more
money they might be able to buy swiss
security might be a better deal but if
it's best for order in their eyes I
think yes they will then indirectly that
is the case so Iook long-term we can't
pay this debt so if we owed Japan the
trillion dollars if they bought a
trillion dollars worth of our Treasury
bills I think they're going to be left
holding the bag that's when I think the
panic is going to come but it finally
dawns on them that they're holding a lot
of lousy debt and they quit buying our
debt that will be the precipitating
event for the crisis and that's when the
then the cartel you know this is a
cartel of central banks and they're
working
well together there's a lot of power
there but I think they'll finally break
up the little cartel and they'll get a
little bit antsy and they won't buy it
out in the panicle start this is there a
potential problem with the buying up of
so much US industry and banks and land
and that is its with ownership comes
control and power so are we through
letting them do this actually giving the
Japanese more and more power over our
decline so a system that's why we should
change our policy that's why we should
have sent money I think it's very
dangerous because we literally will lose
control and that's why I think it's
urgent that we look to balancing a
budget as quickly as possible and
restoring sound money and changing our
foreign policy but if we're concerned
which I think everybody is I don't think
anybody is unconcerned I think some
people come up with different solutions
but I want to not deal with it in the
narrow sense or probably providing some
little rigid rule and say well I can
solve this if we just keep Japan's cars
out of here we're going to solve our car
it's not that easy I mean we have to
look at the big picture of the economy
the monetary system the deficits the
whole thing put together in order to
solve it means it's not easy well thank
you for sharing your time with us thank
you your your background and insight and
we all got to look for some place to go
when that big crash occurs I don't know
where it's going to be but we got to
prepare ourselves we all got to start
studying Japanese and hopefully not